hey it's helping the discussion here and
I'm here with DQ
being strong is not just being strong
you have to be mentally strong as well
you have to have your mind ready when
I'm preparing myself for a big contest I
usually eat around 10,000 colors a day I
eat a lot of sweet potatoes a lot of
good healthy fat like cold oil peanut
butter almonds a good protein right a
lot of axe every day probably 10 to 15
every day meat chicken fish I love fish
weight a lot of greens on my cheat days
I eat whatever I want to like pizza
hamburger ice cream actually I asked him
is not on my cheat day list because I
eat it so often my three tips for
healthy lives that are setting yourself
a great goal if you give yourself a gold
and have your eyes on it's a lot easier
to be focused dedicated having a
training partner is also very important
having someone they're always with you
we can push yourselves you know on those
days when you don't really want to go
train and probably the third one is for
a beginner probably you know having a
trainer having some of their always with
you to help you reach your goals